Dunc Jones here I'm here with Saru
for God's sakes hey hey oh we're goin
you're shooting season 3 already I was
told you just flew from Toronto to be
here for this
how is it going and where are you at in
the filming process of the season
they're right we're not we're about
maybe a third of the way through filming
season three and and we are I know I saw
it I know Mike Steve wants to make sure
that we're I'm talking I love
wider love you guys this is my life 24/7
and so yeah so the story is unfolding at
a rapid pace the writers on this show
just blown up blown us away and I think
I think you know television has gone
shorter with instead of a 22 episode
season we're doing a you know we've been
like anywhere between 13 15 episodes
right which gives a lot more meat to the
episode that you're in and the binge
watching Eric has has made a connective
story tissue happen between all the
episodes that you want watching one big
massive major motion picture and the
effects are so much I mean the
technology and the the cinematic quality
of this show is just like it's
mind-boggling be a part of so so season
three is going to blow you away we jump
to the future yes this is a big deal we
boldly gone where no star series has
gone before so we started before the
original series now we've jumped all the
way till after Voyager so so we're we're
gonna see what happens in the what
condition is the Federation we don't
know yet we're gonna find out when we
land what happens to me and my rank I'm
a commander but I'm also acting captain
to the ship because we lost all our
captains now I take the ship and so do I
get to keep the captain's chair do I
have to give it away to another
Federation Starfleet captain in the
future we're gonna find out all that
when we get there I'm incredibly excited
for service journey because he's been my
favorite character from borrow from the
beginning just all the feeling and
everything going on with him and then
your sister coming in second season
which was awesome
beautiful tell me about what you doesn't
excite you that you've got new species
new planets new creatures you're no
longer beholden to the old timeline you
can now do what you like is there
freedom here that you excited about
there's absolutely freedom we're all
excited about the writers
especially because they're not they
adhered to Canon beautifully in the
timeline before the original series and
they got us in a great transition in
that will go into the original series
now seamlessly now we jumped ahead to
where they can add to Canon they can
they can you know make the Canon a whole
new a new chapter and that's very
exciting for all of us and me being a
kelpy and I'm the first of my kind in
any Star Trek series or film so the
kelpie ins are are proud and strong and
and that last year season two even the
short tracks the short films get it
getting to go back and see where I came
from how my family life was when I was a
teenager looking to the stars and
dreaming about what was ahead there's a
lot of connective tissue there for me as
a person and a lot of our viewers that
we all
that's what Star Trek is so good about
it's about live inning up and making our
own personal dreams possible and that's
the show has really been good for that
and you're as a young kid from Michigan
dreaming of where you're gonna go and
here you are a young kelpy and on this I
mean on in Star Trek right I Indiana I
was growing up in Indiana history of
Hollywood
you can tell casts anbar ladies and
gentlemen is is from the expanse that's
right and we're old friends yes we go
back so I don't know I know we're
everywhere but there's lovely nominated
tonight for a Best Supporting Actor and
so there's a certain is there a certain
kind of pride you feel about being
nominated for a Saturn or because it's
in the world of sci-fi and this award
especially other award shows that are
have their prestige but they they don't
they've never really gotten me and what
I do this is the Academy of voting
members that do get me yeah you know
this is a world that I live in and then
and I've been a geek myself in a nerd
and so we all get each other so it could
be nominated for this this is the most
important award to me personally I have
a warm spot in my heart for the Saturn's
I've been here presenting awards for
many years I've been at this show
countless times I even accepted on
behalf of Guillermo del Toro and seven
four
couldn't be here to pick up his Pan's
Labyrinth award so I've done a lot with
the Saturn's over the years and if it
I've never held my own statues so being
nominated tonight that makes it that
much closer to happening I let's hope I
don't know its own it's always nice to
be nominated it's better to wait exactly
Doug thanks so much for the time man
such a massive fan brother man thank you
same safe